Jaakko had an incident I wanted your
opinion on love your book and podcast
always listen apply your lessons to my
life
job and family I was driving home one
night with my wife and four-year-old son
in the car when some drunk idiot was
walking in the middle of the roadway he
stood in front of my car refusing to
move running his mouth
my wife begged me not to get out of the
car gotta reach to his front reached
into his front waistband like he had a
gun and all and although myself being a
police officer and having countless
incidents and experience like this I
didn't feel he did more like drunken
bravado or grandstanding any case so I
was armed and having trained in boxing
and a little bit of jiu-jitsu felt I
could have handled the situation this
lasted about a minute of him standing
there and eventually I just drove around
him while he was running his mouth
calling me names and all that stuff my
first priority obviously is getting my
family home safely and making sure
nobody will ever do any harm to them but
another part of me felt like what am i
teaching my son I mean is that okay
um you know is that okay to let people
disrespect you at acting anyway they
want towards you so I dropped off my so
I dropped off my family and went back
looking for the guy he was gone I guess
lucky for me as well as him I'm
questioning my decision not out of ego
but only because of the example I want
to be to my son that you never go
looking for trouble and confrontation
but you don't back down from it either
ever okay well just first of all you won
just so you know you won you got a wife
and a kid yeah you won right
so options will be options here but for
one if you're police officer you could
call the police you could you know get
on your radio and call him to say what's
going on and have this guy arrested
before he causes an actual accident
being out in the strode like an idiot
being out in the road like an idiot so
that's an option but but
the other thing is like what are you
trying to teach your son are you trying
to teach your son that he should fight
every idiot that offends him he's if you
if that's what you teach him he is not
gonna have a very productive life or a
very nice life so there's too many
negatives right that can happen there
this actually happened to something
similar to this happen to me a little
while ago I was down by the ocean that
might appear in the neighborhood where I
live and there was a like a Tweaker
crazy you know drunk on drugs and all
that and it was it wasn't as direct as
this he wasn't he wasn't saying anything
me but he's Yellin swear words and and
he's in front of my kid my kid this is
when my son was probably six or seven
years old and he's just alone he's
isolated but he's swearing him just
acting crazy right and what I did was I
said to my son okay you see this guy
right here have you heard of what drugs
are this is what drugs do do right here
this this guy this is where it ends up
so this guy's a miscreant he's a
criminal
you know the other thing I told him I
said what if this guy attacks us what do
you think would happen and my son was
kind of you know well you would choke
him because my son trained you to - at
that time he was well you would choke
him I was like that's right I'm not
afraid of this guy we're not afraid of
this guy
this is no factor cuz we know how to
fight we know how to defend ourselves
but that being said what we want to do
is we want to avoid this situation you
know there's all kinds of all kinds of
bad things that can happen there Lee you
know this I told my son like this guy
could have a knife guy could have a gun
this guy could have this guy could just
have a blood-borne disease right this
guy could have a blood-borne disease now
I go get in a fight with him and now I
have a blood-borne disease you know what
it would it that's horrible it's a
horrible situation so like I said I told
him that this is this is why we trained
this is why we know how to use firearms
because when people are maniacs and and
if they're insane and psychopathic and
they have weapons you need to have a
weapon yourself you need to be able to
defend yourself so
our pride is what I teach my son my
primary objective is to be safe right -
to not get to avoid these situations and
guess what if you still feel the need to
like be a man in the situation or prove
that your man or prove to your son that
which is valuable I'm not trying to put
that down you want your son to see that
that that you should be strong and that
you should be able to stand up for
yourself and that you will don't ever
have to back down to anybody
but that's why your son comes with you
to the gym that's why he trans Jitsu
that's why you trained you so that's why
he watches you day in day out day out
working out being strong being tough
going to the gym training with firearms
that's why he sees all that stuff so he
knows
I mean I'll say right now my kids if you
were to ask my kids like against a
random person in the street they would
they basically think I could beat up
anyone in the world because any training
all the time right that's all they see
me do so so that's that now the
disrespect part the IDE disrespected me
right just respect I'm you know
disrespect me is one thing but now you
disrespect my wife hmm right
well again how can you be disrespected I
know that's what I explained I wouldn't
explain to my son
you cannot just be disrespect be
disrespected by someone that has no
respect for themselves and if you are a
drunk idiot in the street you have no
respect for yourself you don't you
cannot disrespect me it is impossible
for you to give me disrespect you can
even respect yourself as a human so so
that's just that's just it doesn't even
count and I'll tell my son that all day
long or any my kids that all day long
you can't be disrespected by someone
that doesn't even respect themselves you
know what I am respect I'm even
respectful to this drunk idiot giving
him the benefit of doubt I am respect so
you know then the other piece is not
backing down from trouble
right and I'm not gonna back down from
trouble
but I am going to avoid it and I'm gonna
avoid it and you know what trouble
avoids me yeah it avoids me and if you
are working now and you're staying
strong and you have the confidence
because you know you can handle yourself
trouble is going to avoid you 99% of the
time and the other thing is you gotta
tell your kids I mean my son is getting
older now if he gets in a fight with
someone he could kill him I mean that's
just straight-up what could happen and
so now I've got an you know he's a young
kid so he's got a he's got to do the
things that you're talking about in this
question himself who's that he's not
gonna back down I got explained to him
listen let me tell you what comes with
getting in a street fight a cool rush
this is fun right it's fun so you get
that maybe you get a little bit of props
you get a little bit of respect from the
from the you get a cred right some
street cred from your people yeah let me
tell you what else comes with it along
with those two things which are which
are cool right possible jail time
possible injuries possible lawsuits the
broken hand I mean even if it's just
okay those are the big ones right jail
time which there's been plenty of cases
where there was a clay case here in San
Diego guy punched another guy fell on
the curb dead died right now those
things really happen yeah not to mention
you could get you know you get jail time
you get an injury not not to mention you
could get killed right cuz you think
you're a tough guy guess what you're the
greatest MMA fighters in the world get
caught with a crack in the face and they
get knocked out you fall down and hit a
curb you you could die so there's that
aspect too but then you get to the
injuries right cuz you get in a street
fight you're gonna get some kind of an
injury you're gonna get some kind of an
injury it's just gonna happen you know
whether it's just a little cut or a
little brazen you're gonna have
something that's a pain it could be a
major injury you could break your hand
that happens all the time
lawsuits because now you're gonna get
sued you know they're coming after you
and it's just a stupid thing like a rip
jacket or scuff me it just isn't worth
the
it isn't worth it especially because
we're talking about an individual that
you can crush in an instant and that has
no value as a human this fan what this
person's doing right none this person is
an idiot don't go down to their level
and play that game instead avoid that
and go to the gym and train more and be
ready you know that's my opinion good
job on walking away going out to find
the guide luckily you already said
luckily you didn't find it yeah cuz
right now who knows maybe you'd be the
guy that's on you going to jail the cop
that oh you're a cop and you were armed
and you went and got in a fight with
this guy and you pulled your weapon
because you were losing then you shot
him and then what do we see when you see
somebody that had a cell phone and they
recorded the whole thing and they see
you pushing this guy around yeah it's
not a good situation
and you got to be Woltz were responsible
when you're carrying ultra responsible
you're carrying you know that we all
know that when we carry we got to avoid
that's that's what we have to do when
we're packing well yeah and you can kind
of tell when when someone's scared you
know when like if this guy and a guy in
the street and you're in the car that's
I don't know that seems wrong besiege I
run and you go home but you know if
someone's like get it like if you're
walking on the sidewalk and he gets in
your way that's you know it's kind of
different or whatever but avoiding the
situation yeah and you're not scared
because you're prepared or whatever and
you you simply walk around or go the
other way or something like that the
people with you they can tell they can
tell you're not scared
if you tell you're making the rider but
if you are scared whether you fight the
guy or you run away scared they can tell
that to ya so I had another situation
another day I was walking out straight
with my hope well oh yeah with my whole
family
dang yeah going to get some ice cream it
was a couple months goes in the
summertime I'm gonna get some ice cream
hell I had a discipline disciplinary
breakdown in my own mentality I'm just
going to get ice cream yeah
so we're walking down the street and out
of nowhere this guy just gets in my feel
like stood up and got in my face look
really fast and I I just kind of looked
at him and sort of did the you know into
the
semi not a full-on fight stance but I
turned you know like a quarter turn and
just looked at him because I thought
okay we're gonna rock and roll we'll
make this happen any almost instantly
what happened where you just described
it happened as soon as the guy got in my
face he look immediately within what
within a half a second immediately back
down and walked away it was like he was
just trying to prove something then he
realized really quick he was gonna get
crushed yeah but anyways that's the same
thing you know like I could tell oh you
want to fight you know yeah that story
about Malheur
euler gracie : there told me this story
and i guess you know how there's a
really good surfer and ola was out
surfing at a spot in San Diego and you
know San Diego like all surfing areas is
pretty um territorial and there's some
there's some or some aggression in the
surf in anyways some guy started getting
aggressive with with Hoyle ER and Holder
said to him some classic line it was
something along the lines of hey man you
surf for a living I fight for a living
if you want to go to the beach let me
know otherwise be quiet I thought that
was a great line
nicely done all breath this time we win
but it's the same you know when they're
small for those of you don't know who
either Gracie is whole there's a small
small guy he's a obviously a master of
jiu-jitsu but he's only 150 pounds 155
pounds maybe really small guy and he's a
nice guy so he's not a guy that he's not
a guy that's gonna be intimidated he's
not he's not his looks are not going to
intimidate anybody I don't even think he
has cauliflower ears I mean it's just he
just looks like a nice guy and he is a
nice guy and he's got a nice presence
about him yeah so what I'm saying is
what again to reinforce what you just
said when someone is confident to that
level even though they're 145 or 150
pounds and looked like a nice guy with a
smile on their face when you confidently
say look you know what I do for a living
I fight if you want to go to the beach
and fight let me know and the guy says
oh you know what I'm good and I'll just
leave you alone that sounds like a plan
the little detector goes off like danger
you know yeah danger I'm gonna get my
ass beat
yeah but and some but some guys are as
far as decision-making goes some guys
are crazy you know we're like how you
said like if they're like on drugs or
this guy in this case if you sit in the
middle of the road acting like you know
boys in the hood kind we got a problem
here currently that's what he said he
was doing like he's obviously off you
know like he's not a decision-maker kind
of thing so you know if you jump into a
situation with them it's kind of
unpredictable in that weird way you know
yeah let me tell you something else
let's say the guy has a gun or doesn't
have a gun you had the moment to get
away from him yeah if you thought you
had a gun you get away from him right
let's say you said oh you know what I'm
gonna confront him right now so you you
let's say you get a shootout you kill
him guess what you gotta do now you
gotta hire a lawyer you gotta hang up
you gotta take a break from work because
you're a copy there's all these things
not worth but it's just a pain in the
ass is what it is it's almost like I
mean maybe I'm wrong here but it's
almost like you can't really like what
what's the thing what's the goal we're
going for the first question today yeah
what's your reason why yeah your reason
for doing this yeah like I'm gonna go
out and and I'm looking I'm gonna look
for the guy but then like what's the
goal like what's the out like what are
we going for there we go look for him to
tell him not to do that again or what to
arrest enough to kick his ass to believe
right what's going on yeah and then even
that you don't a lot of times we don't I
know when you're in that moment you
don't think past that you're just like I
gotta get my whatever my revenge really
is what it is he shouldn't have done
that to me I'm gonna go teach him a
lesson kind of a thing I mean that's the
feeling ya know yeah but guys are weird
man you can jump into that weirdness but
I just go home if you're family and
watch when the confrontation happens the
best-case scenario isn't good
the best-case scenario oh yeah this is
the best-case scenario that's gonna
happen
yeah it isn't good yeah because you got
even if you walk up and knock the guy
out with one clean punch you gotta you
got a broken finger you know you got a
broken knuckle even if you walk up and
choke the guy you got his grimy puke all
over you know what I mean it's just
there
there's nothing that good is gonna come
out of ya and OH other than it feels
good to fight but that can easily be
remedied by going to the gym and
fighting all your buddies and in this
case I don't know you know this guy oh
you you knocked out a weird homeless guy
in a in the middle of the road and
getting your family like I don't see how
that's cool
yeah no God I mean maybe I don't know if
that would feel good I don't think so
yeah but yeah it's kind of weird this
one time we went on this cruise and it
was me
Terry Tim you know he's like takes huge
joke like I'm kind of big or whatever
Tim and our girlfriends this guy was
behind us in the booth we're at a
restaurant or something and um we were
like what I guess the booths were flimsy
so we're shaking the booth he was behind
us he got up all crazy he's like hey God
yeah you guys are big but you guys keep
knocking the booth we're gonna like
basically called us out to a fight kid
like tattoos everywhere on his neck and
stuff and at first I was like man is
this guy joking over like what's going
on I was confused and to be honest I was
like stunned like almost like I didn't
this scenario was so foreign to me
Oh sniping and not even know what to say
I don't even know what everyone else was
doing
that's how stunned that was but then Tim
he was like he's stacking stuff so he
was like this be serious right now it
just jumps ace that he like stands up
goes to fight him but the guy was a
weirdo that's the thing it was like all
of us big guys you know and Tim was like
he wasn't scared oh he was ready like
fight so it gets in his feet that face
there about if I want us cruised by the
way we're fighting you can't fight on a
cruise No so it's this big scene you
know and the guy like he was like I
don't know I guess he was ready to die
or something because he was like kinda
down the fight and guys came in like I
think broke it up or whatever went to
make this big report it was like this
big thing so it was all just a pain in
the ass is basically right we're saying
like what if we fought that guy you know
the autumn Elizabeth or what if Tim
Potter yeah whatever is getting arrested
yeah you got a lawsuit against him and
we were on a cruise yeah exactly it's
all stupid yeah don't do that Ken stuff